aber ehrlich ich finde finde diese
negativen themen sind irgendwie bis hin
zu präsent in der youtube szenen also
keine ahnung wie neid hass missgunst
services kit und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video und heute rufen wir
was ins leben was es schon lange nicht
mehr gab und zwar gibt es heute eine
neue folge handicap games und die games
sind richtig laut lasst euch die kurz
bis leiser machen die lautstärke im
allgemeinen volle distanz gehen und zwar
lautet die heutige challenge die spring
taste ist verboten das heißt ich darf
heute nur mit doppel b sprinten und das
ist fucking brutal
ich hoffe ich werde irgendwie
vorankommen und falls ich nie sprint
möchte ich nicht so gut trickett nicht
so krass ist verlieren kann dann bitte
hoffentlich ein deathmatch
es ist wie es ist ich nehme auf zack
zack zack
meine mutter kommt dran ja ich weiß wo
sie ein chaos
na gut ja sogar ziemlich lange schön
hart man kann man nicht mal raus wenn
ich zeige dir diese sprünge solche diese
echt brutal mit doppel w und von denen
klicke ich die ganze zeit wie ein
dummkopf hier es also glaubt mir wenn
man das gewohnt ist ist das mit richtig
richtig schwierig ich muss mich jetzt
echt von checkpoint zu checkpoint an ihr
das wird definitiv ein bisschen reggae
im leben
ich finde es überhaupt nicht gewohnt
einfach ohne musik zu zu spielen wenn
wenn leute zum schon irgendwie war ich
einfach voll im stream modus bin ich für
ein paar cent in der letzten zeit jeden
abend quasi übrigens falls ihr euch
dabei war es schaut sehr gerne rein es
geht prinzipiell immer um achtlos der
sportlich genommen so sehr schön hier
zack zack zack zack und dann läuft halt
immer im hintergrund musik und deswegen
ist eine voll komisch jump league zu
spielen ohne dass im hintergrund musik
läuft weil im stream natürlich meine
musik mehr rund laufen werde ich
natürlich selbst auch
aber hier es ist anders aber soweit
stellen wir uns gar nicht schlecht an
richtig richtig brutal wird dann halt
erst wenn irgendwie so ein springer
kommen auf so einzelnen zaun fallen ihr
wisst ich diesen einzelnen chinesen da
das wird richtig richtig hell wie da mit
doppel sprint zu arbeiten weil man da
auch noch ein fachmann laufen muss man
hat ja immer www also man bewegt sich
schon ein stück nach vorne was man wenn
man die taste benutzt nicht hat und das
ist irgendwie richtig richtig richtig
spacey ich muss auch ehrlich sein ich
habe mich in den runden davor viel
blöder angestellt dass jetzt gerade
jetzt wo die aufnahme läuft dem bloody
um die kiste ausgenommen water und wir
sind an die kiste versetzt versetzt ok
krass also die baumscheibe auch die
bestehenden maps um
aha ich hoffe ich dass kein kein
asoziale parcours dann kommt das habe
ich ein richtiges richtiges problem
so sinken darf ich weiterhin ich darf
nur nicht mit der mit der taste sprinten
jetzt hier kommen okay aber es läuft
leute es läuft richtig gut man also ich
will jetzt nicht so krass selbst loben
aber es überrascht mich ja und genau
hier ist es ähnliches problem wenn man
so tempowechsel hat das echt ein problem
habe ich mache so fragt ob er rechne
damit dass nämlich genau die situation
die ich eigentlich nicht haben wenn
dieser challenge dass diese blöden
einzelstücke da kommen so weit gehen wir
aber ganz gut damit um und max wunderbar
leute ich hab gestern abend habe ich
hier auch übrigens noch mal
das los altos schild sein
ich hab mir gestern abend übrigens
gedanken zu einem thema gemacht wow das
war richtig schwierig fakten zum thema
gemacht und zwar zum thema ja zum thema
bescheidenheit auf youtube unter youtube
und dankbarkeit weil ich glaube das ist
echt wirklich nicht weit verbreitet und
ich will jetzt auch nicht der
moralapostel sein aber es ist schon eine
krasse nummer also mann
ich kann jetzt nur von mir berichten bei
mir war es so ich habe mir gehört ja gut
wenn ich jetzt immer irgendwie mal 1500
views auf dem video hat dann ist das
schlecht oder so und habe ich gestern
abend mal irgendwo im streamer
zugeschaut
er hat halt halt drei zuschauer 3 live
zuschauer und er hat sich einfach so
übertrieben gefreut als dann der als an
vierter und fünfter kam und ich habe
dann halt gehostet habt den retweet
gewisse unterstützt voll ausgelastet und
da habe ich mir gedacht wie dumm bist du
eigentlich dass du bei so vielen leuten
die ich gerne schauen sich noch
irgendwie so fühlt als werden es
irgendwie nur eine handvoll und und die
nicht nicht so den nicht den dank zeigt
ihnen zeigen müsste sondern eher
unzufrieden ist das habe ich gestern ein
bisschen bewegt dazu habe ich noch ein
zwei tweets verfasst
und ich find's einfach krass wie sehr
man sich so verbrennen kann und einfach
vollkommen an der realität bei der
realität an der realität vorbei zielt
somit seinen gedanken weil es ist
einfach de facto ist es einfach viel es
sind auch wenn wenn man immer ist es
irgendwo gewohnt und das meine ich man
muss aufpassen dass man sich nicht an
die dinge gewöhnt und die dann
selbstverständlich einen weil es ist
einfach immer noch viel um die 1500
zuschauer oder so das ist einfach
verdammt viel muss man sich mal
vorstellen 1500 leute die irgendwie
freiwillig hinter draufklicken noch
nicht mal gezogen werden es ist einfach
unfassbar
für mich ist es unfassbar
das problem ist dass man sich daran
gewöhnt und wenn man dann irgendwie mal
2500 gewöhnt ist dann denken sich auf
einmal einfach sofort ja ist voll
scheiße aber es ist immer noch verdammt
viel
ja und das ist mir gestern ein bisschen
bewusst geworden und dass man sich
deutlich öfter in bescheidenheit üben
sollte als youtube weil mich alle
schreiben über hater oder über irgendwie
youtube bietet etwa über youtube money
oder so aber letzten endes die dinge
über die wir wirklich momentan schreiben
sollte über die wird einfach gar nicht
berichtet nämlich über sowas
also es muss jetzt kein dauerthema sein
aber ich sehe da aktuell schon bedarf
unter youtube mich eingeschlossen
ich war gestern bis ich bis ich dieses
erlebnis da hatte mancher auf denselben
trip jetzt habe ich mich ein bisschen
bisschen selbst überprüft glaube ich und
ja haben jetzt auch vorgenommen
demnächst einfach mich mir immer
sozusagen und bewusst zu machen wie
viele leute ist doch sind die mich da
irgendwie gerne schauen und den ich auch
hundertprozentig dankbar dafür bin dass
wir an dieser stelle nochmal danke an
alle die jetzt gerade zu schauen oder
überhaupt jemals zugeschaut haben das
ist eigentlich schon eine sehr reale
situation dass so viele leute einem
zuschauern wirklich nur das internet
schafft so eine distanz deswegen ist es
manchmal bisschen komisch ja aber
ehrlich ich finde finde diese negativen
themen sind irgendwie ein bisschen zu
präsent in der youtube sehen also keine
ahnung wie neid hass missgunst whatever
okay dass das ist ein verdammt
schwieriger sprung der berichte ich
richtig schwierig ich finde man sollte
sich bisschen mehr auf die positiven
themen konzentrieren gerade weil die
einfach überhaupt nicht behandelt werden
die in diesem youtube diskurs
wunderbares geschafft leisten
ich muss das hat also wissen flüssiger
machen aber eigentlich ist heute die
themen volker kuhlmann werde ich nicht
gedacht dass ich irgendwie so
funktionieren mit dieser stelle nicht
dass ich über irgendwas reden könnte ich
hätte eher gedacht das wird grausam und
schlimm und scheiße aber
setzt euch an und wir sind im deathmatch
wir haben es nicht bis zum ende
geschafft leider aber 365 blöcke
immerhin finde ich an sich gar nicht mal
schlecht
weißt du jetzt das ist damit das erste
mal dass ich in jump league 4 inch und
bodo zapp natürlich genau dann wenn ich
keinen entspannten tisch ist klar und
ich darf es natürlich auch im deathmatch
nicht sagt zack zack zack ich dachte in
der pony springen muss doppel benutzen
wird auch schwierig gerade wenn ich noch
bei kriege wenn ich geschlagen wäre dann
wieder in die sprinter um reinzukommen
er sitzt gerade schon so bei warendorf
man ist vielleicht fast noch leichter
als hier im anschluss im ersten match
jetzt christian weiß sehr genau dass man
mich ja wunderbar solchen problem jetzt
kannst du nämlich von dem wir hätten
jetzt wo passiert gleichzeitig krass und
da ist der andere
zack zack wunderbare haben den als auch
wunderschön löschen mitgenommen perfekt
ist wie genau hinter dem spawn ereignis
dies ist pci standard war kann jetzt
scheiße kommune ursprünglich faktor ist
so schwierig es so schwierig ohne schone
sprint button zu kommen und ich bin es
überhaupt nicht gewohnt wo alte peter
moore unter acht übrigens was ich noch
sagen wollte heute andere macht wird
wieder in stream geben
ich werde heute auch irgendwann könnten
wir wissen noch nicht genau wie bei
kevin also kupferplatte im stream sein
könnt ihr auch gerne mal reinschauen
ohne um 8 gibt's dann auf meinem channel
auch im stream
eventuell macht mir das zeitgleich über
multitouch also es gibt auf jeden fall
einiges zu sehen heute switch ist in der
beschreibung von lenk trading problem
hoffentlich wirst du auch passiert er
wurde einfach von dem mann an als ob er
den anderen auch gequält hat ach
wahrscheinlich weil es ja dazu kam
dieser isotope wie sie einfach sprint
doch springt doch fakt fucking hell es
lag auch noch wieso alter das ist
richtig schwierig waren
probiert das war wie konnte ich pvp mit
doppel sprint machen wann what the hell
alter das ist so schwierig es ist fast
unmöglich
und möge es fast unmöglich ist ja
vornehmen wenn ich mir von der alle
getroffen werde dann hat jedes mal auf
zu sprinten glaube ich
[ __ ] [ __ ] ich bin raus fit aber ich
konnte ich konnte nichts machen es ist
so schwierig man kommt einfach nicht in
sprint und ein mann steht nur auf der
stelle
wenn man nicht diesen double jumper
crazy alter gut leute wenn euch diese
erste folge handicap games gefallen hat
dann würde ich mich selber live freuen
noch mehr würde ich mich darüber freuen
wenn ihr mir eure eigenen challenges in
die kommentare schreibt und seid so gut
achtet aber darauf dass sie vielleicht
noch kein anderer gemacht hat es muss
nicht unbedingt sein wenn es coole
sachen sind mache ich ja auch mal aber
ich will nicht als jemanden der über
andere kopiert oder so deswegen seid
kreativ aber trotzdem alles rein in die
kommentare was ich so gefällt was ich
ein feld wie selbst nächste video wieder
damals gut an